let's go to roy from south jersey next
welcome roy
hi david hi
so i was wondering um you know biden
said that he would get the equality act
passed within his first hundred days
that didn't happen
uh chuck schumer said he'd bring it to
the floor in june pride month last year
that didn't happen so
do you think it's ever going to happen
uh no probably not
i mean if i'm totally honest with you i
i just i just don't see it happening
anytime soon particularly now um with
what's going on with the shootings
ukraine's still going on midterms coming
up i think now senate's on some kind of
break or was on a break i i i don't see
it i don't see it happening
that's unfortunate now i had another
question um
my both my parents think that the
election was stolen but for various
reasons my mom as you say her mind is
mayonnaise that she thinks the q anon
and
trump won every state
she thinks trump won every state
yes that's even california
that's correct wow
yeah now my dad thinks oh well you know
in pennsylvania they changed the rules
for drop boxes and you know stuff like
that so that's why it's stolen right
which is more dangerous do you think
uh
hmm
well i don't know that the ideas
themselves are necessarily more or less
dangerous it's sort of what people do
with them so i i don't know that i'm
like super crystal clear on it
knowing the two of them do you have a
sense of which is more dangerous
i mean i you know my dad's arguments
make more sense to people even though
they don't make sense okay obviously the
legislators can change the rules to the
elections
that's simple but yeah you know i mean
on paper yes my moms look more more
crazy but my dad seemed to convince more
people so that's you know where i'm
struggling with that that's a common
that's a common thing we've talked about
before
which is
what's worse
a really crazy politician
who can't get anything done but their
ideas are more dangerous versus a
marginally less crazy politician
who
is is less dangerous in their ideas
but might actually be able to make some
of their ideas a reality it's so it's
sort of a similar thing and i think it's
you got to take it on a case-by-case
basis i don't think the the presence of
large swaths of americans believing
either of the things your parents
believe is particularly good let's put
it that way
that's fair yeah no now one last thing
did you see the um the trailer for the
winnie the pooh horror movie no is that
even a thing i've never even heard that
there was a winnie the pooh horror movie
it came out uh recently that this is
happening uh disney lost the rights to
it because some intern forgot to renew
the lease or whatever and uh some guy
picked it up and he's making a horror
movie and it looks terrible but i'm
gonna see it okay wow very good hey
listen one other thing about your
parents
are do either of them have delusional
beliefs about anything other than the
election or is it compartmentalized only
to the election
oh i mean my dad you know he um he's all
right you know he he jokes around a bit
but my mom yeah she's
she's a lunatic on on many fronts oh
like what what other what else does she
believe that she'll mention
well you know she thinks that you know
you can just cure uh
a scratch with just you know healing and
thinking and instead of you know getting
medical advice and whatever okay she
thinks that she cured cancer by you know
wishing it away so you know she's i'm
worried because you know she smokes a
lot and i think she's going to get lung
cancer and then she's not going to get
treatment because she thinks she can
just do this and then she's going to die
you know wait now roy she i'm guessing
you mean she thinks she cured someone
else's cancer with prayer
no her own i don't i don't think she did
have cancer at all so
wait wait oh hold on wait let me so
you're not even sure your mom had cancer
but she believes she had it and cured it
with prayer
that's correct but she was never
diagnosed with cancer
that is correct wow and so why did she
believe she had cancer
uh she had like a lump on her arm or
something
and
she prayed and it went away
yeah
do you think it might have just been
like a cyst or something
it's definitely possible wow wow i feel
really bad for you roy that sounds like
a really tough situation how old a guy
are you
i am 23 24 in the week okay and are you
like out of the home or do you live with
these parents you're describing
i live with my dad my mom's uh separated
got it got it okay wow well listen roy
you've got you've got your hands full
yeah yeah yeah well i appreciate you
sharing your story
thank you all right there's roy wow that
is that is full on that is weaponized
when we talk about weaponized beliefs
that's really what we're talking about
that is uh
that is something
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend
when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video